[Musique]
quand vous dansiez en ce temps-là pas
besoin de Wawa c'était pas la
bossa Noova mais ça remuait bien déjà
les caves étaient profondes et la ronde
ne s'arrêtait pas un vieux piano
bastringue et les dingues tournoyait
déjà
et Juliette avait encore son nez Aragon
n'était pas un minet Sarra était déjà
bien engagé au Café de Flor il y avait
déjà des folles et mon père venait de
débarquer il entait déjà les
boutiquiers dans sa chambre on croquait
du café il ignorait qu'un jour j'en
parlerais quand vous flortiez en ce
temps-là vous vous touchiez du B des
doigts la pilule n'existe sait pas
fallait pas jouer à ces jeu là vous vous
disiez je t'aime parfois même vous
faisiez l'amour aujourd'hui de salades
trois tirad c'est l'affaire qui court
l'oncle adolp s'était déjà flingué son
Eva l'avait
accompagné des fois qu'il aurait voulu
draguer qui sait si là-haut il n'y a pas
des foles et mon père allait bientôt
planter cette graine qui allait lui
donner ce débile qui essait de chanter
il ignorait que viendrai mes
cadets quand vous chantiez en ce tempslà
l'argent ne faisait pas la loi les hites
parades n'existaient pas du moins il
n'était pas de bois tu mettais des
semaines et des semaines parfois des
années si tu avais pas de tripe ta
boutique tu pouvais la fermer et trînet
avait mis des années brassin commençait
à baver et bec atiquit son clavier
monsieur Brell ne parlait pas encore des
folles et mon père venait de débarquer
là où restait quelqu humanité là où les
gens savent encore parler de
l'avenir même s'ils sont
fatigués et Juliette avait encore son
nez Aragon n'était pas un min SRE était
déjà bien engagé au Café de Flor il y
avait déjà des
mon père venait de débarquer il entait
déjà les
boutiquers dans sa chambre on croquait
du café il ignorait qu'un jour j'en
[Applaudissements]
parlerai